So if you've been leading youth for any time, you've probably done a retreat.
And if you've been leading youth for any time, you've done a retreat, then you
probably had that mountaintop experience where students that you did not at all
expect would meet Jesus in that space.
They did. It was awesome.
And you loved every minute of it, right?
And then you come down from the mountain, so to speak.
And then Monday comes, and all of a sudden it starts to feel like we're right
back to where we were.
And I think a lot of that is because it's super cool to love Jesus
when we're at camp, and everybody around us loves Jesus.
And it's super cool to talk about discipleship and spiritual formation and talking
about Jesus to the lost and going out and being a witness for Christ in a world that
desperately needs to hear the gospel.
all that super cool they talk about and it is exciting when we're like in
this little pressure cooker of Christians and then so often we go out
and we send our students out and they come back the same way they were
and we're like what the heck happened and it's because Christianity is
not super cool out there it may be super cool in your youth group which that's
awesome but it's It's not necessarily super cool out there.
It's easy to be a Christian inside the context of a youth group, right?
It's easy to be a Christian when we're up at camp.
It's easy to be a Christian around a bunch of Christians.
But what happens when we need to be a follower of Jesus around everyone else?
It's not so easy. And one thing that your students are going to get a chance to
learn this week is about the lives of the apostles.
Now we don't know a whole lot about the lives of the apostles but what we
do know is that many of them gave and all of them were willing to give
their lives for the message that they preached I love what Peter and John say in
Acts 4:20 that we can do nothing but speak at the things that we have seen and heard
even in the face of persecution where they're being told don't speak about Jesus
anymore because if you do there are going to be serious consequences
guess what they're like no not gonna do it still gonna talk about Jesus
you can't stop us there's nothing that you can do to us to stop us that's awesome
I'm several times I've prayed like man God can I just have that kind
of boldness and yeah I've done the whole thing with my students I've asked them you
know if someone held a gun to your head and told you to denounce Jesus would And
that may be becoming more of a reality in our world now more than ever.
But the bottom line is, is we want our students to see
the power of the Holy Spirit in our lives and the power of the gospel and
how it ought to compel us to move into spaces where the gospel needs us most
despite the fear, despite the difficulty.
And that really becomes the focus this week as you kind of get into some things.
We want students to know that the apostles were not liars, that despite what some
people say, they didn't make this stuff up because why would you give your life over
for something that you know is completely a lie?
That doesn't quite work. And that they're willing to die for this belief.
That's a profound reality for our students to kind of get after.
And it should be a very transformative experience for them.
Okay, so I know what many students are probably going to say to you.
and you're probably going to hear this.
Others have died for their belief, especially in our world.
We hear about it all the time, especially with terrorism, that others die for their
belief. What makes the apostles so much different, right?
They're fervent too. They think what they believe is right.
How come the apostles... Yeah, that's absolutely true.
But here's the difference, and this is something you're going to hear Sean say, and
I'm just going to echo it. If I died for my faith and I proclaim it to be true,
that's just because I think it's true.
It doesn't necessarily make it true.
It's because it's been passed down to me.
And what I think I've got it all figured out.
I think I've got it all right. And I'm going to believe that I do.
But the difference is, is that the apostles saw and were eyewitnesses
to Jesus. They, That's why they're apostles, is they actually lived
with Jesus, walked with Jesus, saw him die, saw him resurrect, were given the
instructions, and they died as a result of that belief.
And it's a direct correlation, right?
So you've got this piece that is, here is Jesus, this counter-cultural
public figure, icon, religious type
person that is spreading news that is totally contrary to
what the mainline beliefs, whether you were Jewish or Roman, were.
So there was fear. There was animosity.
It was like, who is this guy? What is he doing?
What's going on? So once he was gone, it was like, whew, he's out.
We're done. Let's move on. And then all of a sudden these apostles, these people
that were with Jesus start carrying this on.
Now imagine for a moment that this is not true.
And you're one of the apostles, and you get told, shut it down, or you're going to
lose your life. What do you pick?
I'm not going to carry this lie.
There's nothing in it for me. What do I care?
You're not going to die for something you know is a lie.
But they so believed it. The resurrection changed them so much that
they were willing to have their lives put to an end in some horrific ways, mind you.
Now, it doesn't prove anything beyond a shadow of a doubt,
But it does show that the apostles were not lying.
So in your small group time, focus in on the student discussion questions.
Specifically, how would you describe the conviction the apostles had for their
message? Dive into that a little bit deeper.
Like, how would you describe their conviction?
And do you agree with their conviction?
Ask your students honestly, did these apostles seem absolutely out of their minds?
Like, why would you do this? Or is there something more going on here and then help
them make the connection of well what if you were there try to connect them to
uh and bridge the gap between then and now and bring your students into that space
now find an example find something that will help them understand if you absolutely
saw something and you knew it to be true how far would you go to make sure that
truth came out. How far would you go?
We see it all the time in movies and media and music and other places where we want
the truth to come out, and we're willing to go to great lengths to make sure of
that. So how far would they go? And the third one is, what fate did the apostles
meet due to their relentless devotion to spreading the gospel?
Have them look back into that. Now there's some wide disagreement on the exact fate
of some of the exact ones, and you can look into that.
Be careful what you find if you go looking on the internet.
Not all of it is 100% accurate. There's some things that are church tradition, not
necessarily historically accurate.
But it still makes the point that they did suffer and die as a result.
How they suffered and died is a little bit up for debate.
But we know that they did for sure.
And lastly what does the apostle's fate
mean for this faith of your students this is kind of going to get into the nitty
-gritty of things because this seems so distant right this seems so far off
something so uh so old and it doesn't really matter anymore it doesn't concern me
I'm in a nice comfy whatever it's fine bring it what does it
mean for them.
Have them think that through and talk through specifically.
Make them dig deep. If they kind of give an answer that you're like, ask them why.
Ask them to go a little bit deeper and really pull out of them what it would mean.
And what does it now mean moving forward?
How are they going to live differently?
How are they going to act differently knowing this information?
Then take some time and look at, take back what you've looked at over the last
couple of weeks. You've got miracles.
A miracle is verifiable. It's testable.
We know that miracles exist. We see the greatest miracle in the history of the world
and the resurrection of Jesus.
That resurrection miracle solidifies the claim that Jesus is
God, the creator of all, and that that message of the gospel and who
Jesus is and what was going on in the world was so compelling, so powerful, so life
-changing that the apostles who saw it, witnessed it, and lived it died because
of it.
That's powerful, powerful testimony.
Have your students look back on the whole blanket of concepts that we've just laid
out over the last four weeks. And have them take a hard look at their faith and say,
now how do I move with all this knowledge?
I can't stay here. I can't just know this and move on.
And now that I know all of this, what does it look like for me moving forward in my
walk with Christ?